well as I say it came out of a natural
course out of my research and sensory
deprivation which is the opposite
Cynthia sensation-seeking but I must
admit perhaps I was at the time of my
life you know I looked at people and
friends who are higher sins hi sensation
seekers and I look at that one psycho I
use them as well I kind of a prototype
when I was designing this straight but
oh well what would they one of the
things they do what do they like you
know it's kind of prototype for writing
items for my scale mountains of course
it went you know we have other ways then
once we had these items we have to have
the idea it was a new idea for a trait
it was a new Kia which no one was really
measuring at that time ok so to get my
idea i looked around it you know and
what people were doing and I said and I
am I in the first form of this test we
dependent on I'd like to do we say would
you like to do this like would you like
to do parachutes skydiving you know
because we assume most people aren't
doing it but the near liking to the
wanting to think thought they would like
to do it is something that characterize
a higher sensation figure ok whereas a
lower sensations no that's crazy why
would I want to do that you know that's
dangerous so in what people might like
to do well as our first items for our
thrill and adventure seeking subscale ok
then we asked what what about be well we
know one of the other aspects oh yeah
when we looked at sex drugs and we asked
questions about the would you like to do
this would you like to do that or in the
case of sex what do you like to do you
know or what are your attitude store
that they permissive attitude some of
those sort of things we looked at so
that's how I got the initial items now
we have different kinds of items now the
don't include content just a need for
excitement
well I would say to be a publishing
professor teaching you can't be too high
because if you're too high you know you
know you're out of y'all doing other
things not you're not doing research and
writing so but I was i would say i was
higher than the average than the average
professor okay now recently that became
a moot point when they discovered this
gene the doping for receptor gene now i
was in england by this time I was
getting on an age my it was my last
sabbatical but I had the chance I was in
the genetics lab there and I had the
chance to have my own DNA examined for
the presence of this particular gene the
form of the gene so I didn't I found I
had the long form of the gene which is
the type associated with
sensation-seeking but as I explained to
my colleagues there my sensation seeking
at that by the time he was 16 my
sensation seeking was confined to
writing the top of the double-decker bus
in London you know because eight you
know you may have a gene for something
but the its expression is affected by
other biological factors related to age
normally like the rise in mao with age
which reduces sensation-seeking
you